hello everyone and welcome to this
amazing video on kuber NS you're
watching your very own simply learn
YouTube channel so make sure to
subscribe to a YouTube channel and like
this video in this comprehensive
kubernets tutorial we will discuss the
entire process of how kubernets
automates operational task of container
management we will understand containers
right from scratch and move on to more
advanced topics covering each and every
step with detailed Hands-On
demonstration this tutorial will ensure
that you get an exhaustive understanding
of kubernets its architecture and how to
use youber needs for container
management with that being said make
sure to comment your opinion on this
video And subscribe to us to never miss
any other the amazing Tech content we
bring just for you let's get started
just a quick info for you if you want to
upskill yourself master devop skills and
land your dream job or grow in your
career then you must explore simply
learns cohort of various devops programs
simply learn offers various
certification and post-graduate programs
in collaboration with some of the
world's leading universities like
Caltech and Google Cloud through our
courses you will gain knowledge and work
ready expertise in skills like devops
methodology deployment automation cicd
Pipeline and over a dozen others that's
not all you'll also get the opportunity
to work on multiple projects and learn
from industry experts working in Top
Tire product companies and academian
from top universities after completing
these courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into devops role as a
fresher or move on to a higher paying
job role and profile so if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comments and
description box to find devops program
that fits your expertise and areas of
Interest hello and welcome to Simply
learn in this session we're going to
cover what kubernetes is and why you
would want to be using it within your
devops team but before we get started
remember to hit the like button if you
like this video and the Subscribe button
if you want to get notified about more
of these videos as they come out and as
always if you have any comments about
the content that we're covering or
questions that you have on the subject
please post them in the comments below
so let's get started we're going to
break up this presentation into four key
areas we're going to talk about life
before kubernetes which some of you are
probably experiencing right now what is
kubernetes the benefits of kubernetes
brings to you particularly if you are
using containers in a Dev Ops
environment and then finally we're going
to break down the architecture and
working infrastructure for kubernetes so
you understand what's happening and why
the actions are happening the way way
that they are so let's jump into our
first section of life before kubernetes
so the way that you have done work in
the past or you may be doing work right
now is really building out and deploying
Solutions into two distinct areas one is
a traditional deployment where you're
pushing out code to physical servers in
a Data Center and you're managing the
operating system and the code that's
actually running on each of those
servers another environment that you may
potentially be using is deploying code
out out to Virtual machines so let's go
through and look at the two different
types of deployment that you may be
experiencing when you have applications
running on multiple machines you run
into the potential risk that the setup
and configuration of each of those
machines isn't going to be consistent
and your code isn't going to work
effectively and there may be issues with
uptime and errors within the
infrastructure of your entire
environment there's going to be problems
with resource allocation and and you're
going to have issues where applications
may be running effectively and not not
effectively and not load balance um
effectively across the environment the
problem that you have with this kind of
infrastructure is that it gets very
expensive uh you can only install one
piece of software one service on one
piece of Hardware so your Hardware is
being massively underutilized this is
where virtual machines have become
really popular with a virtual machine
you're able to have better resource
utilization and scalability at much less
cost and this allows you to be able to
run multiple virtual machines on a
single piece of Hardware the problem is
is that VMS or for virtual machines are
not perfect either some of the
challenges you run with VMS is that the
actual hardware and software need needed
to manage the VM environment can be
expensive there are security risks with
virtual with VMS there are security
risks with VM there have been data
breaches recorded about solutions that
run in virtualized environments you also
run into an issue of availability and
this is largely because you can only
have a finite number of virtual machines
running on a piece of hardware and this
results in limitations and restrictions
in the types of environment you want to
be running and then finally setting up
and managing a virtualized environment
is time consuming uh it can take a lot
of time and it can also get very
expensive so how about kubernetes well
kubernetes is a tool that allows you to
manage containerized deployment of
solutions and inherently kubernetes is a
tool that is really a Next Level
maturity of deployment so if you can
think of your maturity curve as
deploying code in directly to Hardware
in a Data Center and then deploying your
solutions to Virtual machines the next
evolution of that deployment is to use
containers and kubernetes so let's kind
of go through and look at the
differences between a virtual machine
and kubernetes and we've got a few here
that we want to highlight and you'll get
an understanding of what the differences
are between the two so first of all with
virtual machines there is inherently
security risks and what you'll find as
we get dig through the architecture
later in the presentation is that
kubernetes is inherently secure um and
this is largely because of the leg
Legacy code uh the legacy of kubernetes
and where it came from we will talk
about that in just a moment but
kubernetes is inherently secure uh
virtual machines are not easily portable
now with that said they they are
technically portable they're just not
very easily portable whereas with
kubernetes it's working with Docker
container Solutions it is extremely
portable that means that you can
actually spin up and spin down and
manage your infrastructure exactly the
way that you want it to be managed and
scale it on the demands of the customers
as they're coming in to use the solution
from a timec consuming point of view
kubernetes is much less time consuming
than with a virtual machine a few other
areas that we want to kind of um
highlight differences virtual machines
use much less isolation when than
building out the encapsulated
environment than kubernetes does uh for
instance with a virtual machine you have
to run hypervisor on top of the OS and
hard hardware and then inside of the
virtual machine you also have to have
the operating system as well whereas in
contrast on a kubernetes environment
because it's leveraging a darker
container and or container like
Technologies it only has to have the OS
and the hardware and then inside of each
container it doesn't need to have that
additional OS layer it's able to inherit
what it needs to be able to run the
application this makes the whole
solution much more flexible and allows
you to run many more containers on a
piece of Hardware then versus running
virtual machines on a single piece of
Hardware so as we highlighted here VMS
are not as portable as kubernetes and
kubernetes is portable directly related
to the use of containerization and
because kubernetes is built on top of
containers it is much less time
consuming because you can actually
script and automatically allocate
resource to nodes within your kubernetes
environment this allows the
infrastructure to run much more
effectively and much more efficiently so
this is why if we look at our evolution
of the land of time before kubernetes
while we are running into a solution
where kubernetes had to come about
because the demand for having more
highly scalable solutions that are more
efficient was just really a natural
evolution of this software deployment
model that started with pushing out code
to physical hardware and then pushing
code out to Virtual machines and then
needing to have a solution much more
sophisticated kubernetes would have come
about at some point in time I'm just
really glad it came about when it did so
what is kubernetes let's this dig into
the history of kubernetes and how it
came about so in essence kubernetes is
an open-source platform that allows you
to manage and deploy and maintain groups
of containers and a container is
something like Docker and if you're
developing code you're probably already
using doer today consider kubernetes as
the tool that manages multiple docker
envir environment together now we talk a
lot about darker and as a container
solution with kubernetes the reality is
is that kubernetes can actually use
other container tools out there but
Docker just simply is the most popular
container out there both of these tools
are open source that's why they're so
popular and they just allow you to be
able to have flexibility in being able
to scale up your Solutions and they were
designed for the postd digital world
that we live and exist in today so a
little bit of background a little bit of
trivia around kubernetes uh so
kubernetes was originally a successor to
a project at Google and the original
project was Google Bor um Google Bor it
does exactly what kubernetes done does
today but kubernetes was Rewritten from
the ground up and then released as an
open-source project in 2014 so that
people outside of Google could take
advantage of the power of kubernetes
containerization management tools and
today it is managed by the cloud native
Computing foundation and there are many
many companies that support and manage
kubernetes so for instance if you're
signing up for Microsoft Azure AWS
Google Cloud all of them will leverage
kubernetes and it's just become the the
de facto tool for managing large groups
of containers so let's kind of Step
through some of the key benefits that
you'd experience from kubernetes and so
we have nine key benefits and the first
it is highly portable at is 100%
open-source code and this means that you
can actually go ahead and contribute to
this code project if you want to through
GitHub uh the ability to scale up the
solution is incredible um what's um the
the history of kubernetes being part of
a Google project for managing the Google
network and infrastructure uh kind of
really sets the groundwork for having a
solution that is highly scalable the out
of the high scalability also comes the
need for high availability and this is
the desire to be able to have a highly
efficient and highly energized
environment that also you can really
rely on so if you're building out a
kubernetes management um environment you
know that it's going to be um available
for the solutions that you're
maintaining and it's really designed for
deployment so you can script out the
environment and actually have it as part
of your devops model so you can scale up
and meet the demands of your customer
then what you'll find find is that the
um load balancing is extremely efficient
and it allows you to distribute the load
efficiently across your entire network
so your network remains stable and then
also the tool um allows you to U manage
the orchestration of your storage so you
can have local storage such as an SSD on
the hardware that the kubernetes is M
maintaining or if the kubernetes
environment is pulling storage from a
public Cloud such as Azure or AWS you
can actually go go ahead and make that
available to your entire system and you
can inherit the security that goes back
and forth between the cloud environments
and one of things you'll find consistent
with kubernetes is that it is designed
for a cloud first environment um
kubernetes as well is that it's it's
really a self-healing environment so if
something happens or something fails uh
kubernetes will detect that failure and
then either restart the process kill the
process or replace it and then because
of that you also have automated roll
outs and roll backs uh in case you need
to be able to manage the state of the
environment and then finally uh you have
automatic bin packaging so you can
actually specify the compute power
that's being used from CPU and RAM for
each container so let's dig into the
final area which is the actual
kubernetes architecture and we're going
to cover this at a high level there's
actually another video uh that you can
that simply learn has developed which
digs deeper into the kubernetes
architecture and so the kubernetes
architecture is a cluster based
architecture and it's really about two
key areas you have the kubernetes master
which actually controls um and all of
the activities within your entire
kubernetes infrastructure and then you
have nodes um that actually are running
on Linux machines um out that are
controlled by the master so let's kind
of go through some of these um areas so
if we look at the kubernetes master uh
to begin with um then we'll start with
with uh Etc this is a tool that allows
for the configuration of information and
the management of nodes within your
clust and one of the key features that
you'll find with all of the tools that
are managed within either a the master
environment or within a node is that
they are all accessible via the API
server um and what's interesting about
the API server is that it's a restful
based infrastructure which means that
you can actually secure each connection
with s L um and other um security models
to ensure that your entire
infrastructure and the communication
going back and forth across your
infrastructure is tightly secured
scheduler goes ahead and actually as
you'd expect actually um manages the
schedule of activities within the actual
cluster and then you have the controller
and the controller is a Damon server
that actually manages and pushes out the
instructions to all of your noes so uh
the other tools really are the uh the
infrastructure and and you can consider
them the administration site of the
master whereas controller is the
management it actually pushes out all of
the controls via the API server so
that's actually dig into um one of the
actual nodes themselves and there are
three key areas of the nodes one is the
do environment which actually helps and
manage and maintain the container that's
actually inside um of the node and then
you have the kuet which is responsible
for information that goes back and forth
and it's going to do most of the
conversation with the API server on the
actual health of that node and then you
have the actual kubernetes proxy which
actually runs the surfaces actually
inside of the node so as you see all of
these infrastructures are extremely
lightweight and designed to be very
efficient and very available for your
infrastructure and so here's a quick
recap of the different tools that are
available and it really breaks down into
two key areas you have your kubernetes
master and the kubernetes node now the
kubernetes master has the instructions
of what is going to happen within your
kubernetes infrastructure and then it's
going to push out those infrastructure
to an indefinite number of nodes that
will allow you to be able to scale up
and scale down your solution in a
dynamic way hi guys in today's video I
going to show you how to install Ubuntu
on kubernetes kubernetes is an open-
Source platform used for deployment and
management of containers so let's get
started now the first step is to install
the necessary dependencies using two of
the commands first is PSE sudo app get
update which gets all the
updates and then you have to enter
password so this will take a few
seconds that's done the next step is to
install app transport https this is
basically used to make repositories via
https so let's go ahead with that
sudu okay that's done going ahead the
next thing we have to do is to install
the docker dependency using the command
sudo app install docker.io
you have to choose
why and this will take a few
minutes okay that's done so after
installing the docker we have to start
and enable the docker using the command
sudo system CTL start Docker and sudo
system CTL enable
Docker so now the docker is enabled so
now we done with the first step of
installation the next step is we have to
install the necessary components for
kuties before that we have to install
the curl command because curl command is
used to send data using a URL syntax
let's install the Cur command using the
command sudo app get install code
[Music]
so you have to select Y and this will
take few
minutes so moving on the next step we
have to do is download and add key for
kubernetes installation from a URL so
let's go ahead with that pseudo
curl so this is where we get the key and
then we have to add it using pseudo AP
key ad and it's done so the next step is
we have to add a repository in a certain
location so before doing that we have to
change the permission of that file so we
do that using C or sudo CH mode
command Okay so the permission is
changed now let's go ahead and save this
file in that location first we have to
enter this command into the file this is
a
URL save
as so we have have to save it in this
location let's rename this to
kubernetes do
list now let's
see okay so here it is now moving
forward now we have to check for any
updates
available in the next command we are
going to install the kubernetes
components that is cubet Cube ADM cubec
and kuet cni so let's go ahead with
that
so this is going to take a few
minutes now that's done so the next step
we have to initialize the master node
and to do this we have to first use a
swap off command to disable the swapping
on other devices so let's do that sud
sudo swap off hyper now let's go ahead
with the initialization
sudo cube adum in it this is going to
take a few
minutes okay so before going to the next
step to start the cluster we have to use
these three commands let's just copy
paste
it okay that's done so moving forward
the next step is to deploy pods using
the following
[Music]
command now the pods have been deployed
to our Network to see all the pods you
have to use the command sudu cubic get
pods there you can see the p that been
de hello and in this video we're going
to cover a common conversation which is
kubernetes versus darker but before we
jump into that I want you to hit the
Subscribe button so you get notified
about new content as it gets made
available and If you hit the
notification button that notification
will then pop up on your desktop as a
video is published from Simply learn in
addition if you have any questions on
the topic please post them in the
comments below we read them and we do
reply to them as often as we can so with
that said let's jump jump into
kubernetes versus Docker so let's go
through a couple of scenarios let's do
one for kubernetes and then one for
Docker and we can actually go through
and understand what the problem specific
companies have actually had and how
they're able to use the two different
tools to solve them so our first one is
with Bose and Bose um had a large
catalog of products that kept growing
and their infrastructure had to change
so the way that they looked at that was
actually establishing two primary goals
uh to be able to allow their product
groups to be able to easier more easily
catch up to the scale of their business
so after going through um a number of
solutions they ended up coming up with a
solution of having kubernetes running
their iot platform as a service inside
of Amazon's AWS cloud service and what
you'll see with both these products is
they're very Cloud friendly but here we
have um Bose and kubernetes working
together with AWS to be able to scale up
and meet the demands of their product
catalog and so the result is that we
were able to increase the number of
nonpr production deployments
significantly by taking the number of
services from being large bulky Services
down to small micr Services being able
to handle as many as
1250 plus deployments every year an
incredible amount of time and value has
been opened through the use of
kubernetes now let's have a look at
Docker and see what similar problem that
people would have so uh the problem is
with PayPal and PayPal processes
something in the region of over 200
payments per second across all of their
products and PayPal doesn't just have
PayPal they have brain Tre and venmo so
the challenge um that uh PayPal was uh
really being given is that they had
different architectures which resulted
in different maintenance cycles and
different deployment times and an
overall complexity for from having a
decades old architecture with PayPal
through to a modern architecture with
venmo through the use of docka PayPal
was able to unify the application
delivery and be able to centralize the
management of all of the containers uh
with one existing group the net net
result is that PayPal was able to
migrate over 700 applications into
Docker Enterprise which consists of over
200,000 containers this ultimately
opened up a
50% increase in availability for being
able to add in additional time for
building testing and deploying of
applications just a huge win for PayPal
now let's dig into kubernetes and Docker
so kubernetes is an opensource platform
and it's designed for being able to
maintain a large number of containers
and what you're going to find is that
your argument for kubernetes versus
Docker isn't a real argument it's
kubernetes and Docker working together
so kubernetes is able to manage the
infrastructure of a containerized
environment and Docker is the number one
container management solution and so
with Docker you're able to automate the
deployment of your applications being
able to keep them in a very lightweight
environment and being able to uh create
a nice consistent experience so that
your developers are working in the same
containers that are then also pushed out
to production so with doer you're able
to manage multiple containers running on
the same Hardware much more efficiently
than you are with a VM environment the
productivity around Docker is extremely
high you're able to keep your
applications very isolated uh the
configuration for Docker is really quick
and easy you can be up and running in
minutes with Docker once you have it
installed and running on your
development machine or inside of your
devops environment so we look at the
deployment between the two um and the
differences kubernetes is really
designed for a combination of PODS and
services in its deployment whereas with
Docker it's around about deploying
services in containers uh so the the
difference um here is that kubernetes is
going to manage the entire environment
and then and that environment consisting
of PODS and inside of a pod you're going
to have all of your containers that
you're working on and those containers
that can control the services that
actually power the applications that are
being deployed kubernetes is by default
an autoscaling solution it has it turned
on and is always available whereas
Docker does not and and that's not
surprising because Docker is a tool for
building out Solutions whereas
kubernetes is about managing your
infrastructure kubernetes is going to um
run health checks on the liveness and
Readiness of your entire environment so
not just one container but tens of
thousands of containers whereas Docker
is going to limit the health check to
the services that it's managing within
its own containers now I'm not going to
kid you kubernetes is quite hard to set
up it's it's if of the tools that you're
going to be using in your devop
environment it's it's not an easy setup
for you to use um and for this reason
you want to really take advantage of the
surfaces within Azure and other similar
Cloud environments where they actually
will do the setup for you Docker in
contrast is really easy to set up you as
I mentioned earlier you can be up and
running in a few minutes as you would
expect the fault tolerance within
kubernetes is very high and this is by
Design because the architecture of
kubernetes is built on the same
architecture that Google uses for
managing its entire Cloud infrastructure
in contrast Docker has lower fault
tolerance but that's because it's just
managing the the services within its own
containers what you'll find is that most
public Cloud providers will provide
support for both both kubernetes and
Docker here we've highlighted Microsoft
Azure because they were very quick uh to
jump on and support kubernetes uh but
the realities is that today Google
Amazon and many other providers are
having first level support for
kubernetes it's just become extremely
popular in a very very short time frame
the company's using both kubernetes and
Docker is vast and every single day
there are more and more companies using
it and you should be able to look and
see whether or not you can add your own
company to this list hello and welcome
to Simply learn today we're going to be
giving you a kubernetes tutorial we will
provide the overview of how and why you
should be using kubernetes but before we
get started don't forget to hit the
Subscribe button and the like button if
you want to get notified about
additional content from Simply learn and
as always if you have any comments about
the material that you're about to see
and you have any questions please post
them in the comments below we do read
them and we do reply to them so with
that said let's jump in so we're going
to go through a bunch of things today
around kubernetes we're going to cover
what kubernetes is and why you should be
using it along with the features of
kubernetes we're also going to take a
little bit of a look at kubernetes
versus Docker swarm as the two
technologies do tend to get referred to
quite frequently and then we're going to
do a deep dive into the actual
kubernetes architecture itself and how
uh kubernetes runs and operates within
your network and then finally we're
going to look at some kubernetes use
cases of how you can actually apply um
best learnings that other companies have
used with kubernetes we'll finish
everything off with a demo where we
actually step through and use some of
the actual codes that you can actually
use to run uh from your terminal window
to actually activate kubernetes itself
so with that said let's jump in so why
kubernetes well kubernetes is really
being built from allowing you to be able
to have a more reliable infrastructure
uh the tool itself is designed to manage
the containers you have within your
network it's very modular in
architecture which allows it to be very
easy to be able to maintain and to be
able to scale and meet the demands that
your current customers are offering you
today the actual ability for you to be
able to deploy an update software at
scale is really at the heart and center
of kubernetes it's really the one of the
reasons why kubernetes was created was
to be able to scale up the deployment of
software to tens of thousands of
networks and servers uh within a Data
Center and then finally uh when you
start working with kubernetes really
what you doing is laying the foundation
for building Cloud native applications
and part of this comes from the
architecture and history of kubernetes
which we get to in a little bit but it's
good to know that as you're using
kubernetes and containerized solutions
that you're really building out an
infrastructure that's designed for cloud
Centric solution delivery so let's dig
into why what kubernetes is so the
history of kubernetes is that it was
originally developed by Google Google
actually H used the precursor to
kubernetes to manage and maintain the
data structure and data infrastructure
that they had within their Network they
really liked it and one of the big
benefits that kuber that Google provided
is that they uh converted their code
into an open source program that they
released as kubernetes in 2014 and made
an open source this means that anyy can
use kubernetes there's no charge for it
all you have to do is know how to use
the command lines to actually get up and
running the benefit of kubernetes being
open source is that most Cloud providers
now support kubernetes so whether you're
using Microsoft Azure you're using
Google cloud or AWS you'll find that you
can actually use kubernetes and
kubernetes and at it core really helped
eliminate manual processes so it allows
for deploying and scaling your container
based Solutions much more more
effortless within a cloud environment so
let's jump into the features of
kubernetes and why you'd want to be
using it and we have a number of
features that we want to kind of Step
through again the first thing that
kubernetes is a strong benefit of is
that it eliminates those manual
processes and allows you to automate
them the benefit you have from this is
that you can then scale up your
automation across your entire network so
whether you are managing 10 nodes um
within your network or whether you're
managing 10,000 uh doesn't matter you
have the ability to scale that something
you simply didn't have before kuet is
also will manage the actual containers
themselves um including the security the
storage and the networking within those
containers the great uh benefit of
working with kubernetes is that not only
is it a cloud Centric solution but it
was really built from a core need of a
secure solution so security is at the
heart and center of all the work you're
doing
which really helps benefit any teams
scaling out containers your kubernetes
environment will be constantly monitored
so that when you have nodes that have
your containers the health of those
nodes is being constantly communicated
back to C the um kubernetes environment
so that the entire environment is always
being managed and checked so if you have
any um additional hosting and launching
that needs to be done uh kubernetes will
U help you automate those manual
processes if something does go wrong you
can actually set up your kubernetes
environment to do an automatic roll back
again this is just allowing you to have
that confidence that when you're
deploying a solution that everything is
going to work within that environment
and then finally kubernetes will allow
you to mount and add the storage needed
to run your apps so whether you have
storage such as a local SSD storage
device uh physically on the hardware or
if you're um connecting to storage fire
the cloud kubernetes will allow you to
access the storage you need how you're
accessing it so let's look a little bit
into uh the differences between
kubernetes and Docker swarm so if we
just step back a little bit uh
kubernetes and Docker often get
connected with each other uh largely
because kubernetes manages containers
and Docker is really famous for creating
the most popular uh container management
solution which is called Docker um if
you're a developer you're probably
already using Docker today so one of the
things that kubernetes is really really
good at is that it manages containers at
scale just massive volume of containers
Docker swarm is docker's alternative to
kubernetes it's a tool that allows you
to also manage large number large
numbers of containers um there are
differences between the two of them and
right now without doubt the most popular
um open source solution out there is Ku
kubernetes from Google uh it just has a
massive Community behind it and uh the
community uh really have embrac um
kubernetes um yes the original product
was by developed by Google but Google
has been great stewards and they've
allowed the community to drive the
future evolution of the product uh
Docker swarm is actually managed and
developed by Docker um there is a
smaller Community but it is also a very
passionate community and the reason
being is that both products are actually
pretty good and you just really kind of
have to choose which one you want to go
with without doubt there is more
customization and extensions built for
kubernetes simply because the community
is just so much bigger than the docker
swarm community and but with that said
Docker swarm is really easy to set up so
if you are used to working within the
docker environment you'll be able to set
up Docker swarm very very quickly
whereas kubernetes does require some
heavy lifting to get up and running now
with that said if you are using
Microsoft Azure or Google Cloud very
often those environments will actually
set up kubernetes for you so you don't
have to do it and you can actually then
focus on writing the instructions to
maintain your kubernetes environment uh
kubernetes um has extremely um High
fault tolerance again um it's because
kubernetes is has been R tested the
foundation for kubernetes is based on
managing sites such as Gmail
google.com YouTube I mean just
incredibly robust environment compared
to dock swarm which has lower fault
tolerance um and this really kind of
leads into um the final areas where
kubernetes um does guarantee um strong
clusters management just a really
reliable environment Dr swarm however is
able to uh take containers deploy them
into large custers very very quickly two
interesting different differences is
that with kubernetes the load balancing
is still manual and be interesting to
watch how kubernetes matures that skill
set uh in contrast load balancing is
automatic within Docker swarm so let's
dig into the kubernetes architecture and
just kind of expose some of those key
elements um if you're interested in
actually having a very deep dive into
kubernetes architecture we have already
got another video and we should have a
link in the comments that you can select
that will take you to that video as well
and but this will provide you an
overview as well um so the way that
kubernetes runs is that it uses nodes to
actually manage all the individual
Hardware within a specific unit and so a
node is really a physical machine uh in
a data center uh or a virtual machine
and when you're setting up an
environment on a cloud environment such
as Microsoft Azure or Google cloud or
AWS kubernetes will be managing the
containers within that node so it's
important to know that kubernetes itself
doesn't work with the individual node
but actually works with the cluster as a
whole and and why that's important is
that it's a tool to manage your entire
environment it's not going to come down
and manage the individual node itself
it's going to manage the entire
environment the actual control of data
within a cluster um is very very
flexible within kubernetes you can have
local storage such as an SSD uh card or
a traditional local storage or you can
actually connect to the cloud and use
cloud-based storage and the benefit that
cloud-based storage offers you is that
you are increasingly Moving Your
solution into more of a hardwarefree
environment cloudbased architecture
where you're not riant on a physical
piece of Hardware within your data
center and why that's important is that
it gives you the opportunity to scale up
your Solutions much more effectively so
if you need to increase the hard drive
space you can do that very easily from
the cloud Wares local hardware is a
little bit harder to match great news
kubernetes gives you both options to be
able to choose from and so the the next
layer down is the actual management of
the application and that's within a
container and as mentioned earlier
Docker is the most popular container
solution out there and again if you're a
developer you're probably already using
Docker as it was a natural maturity from
using a virtual machine but kubernetes
itself will actually manage the
containers that you have within your
nodes and so you have a collection of
containers working together and then you
pull those together into what's called a
pod and what's great is kubernetes will
actually manage the health of that pod
so if a container or a pod fails
kubernetes will automatically deploy out
a replica so your entire environment can
stay running and being efficient and so
the pots themselves U will actually be
managed by kubernetes and you really
want to uh let kubernetes um do this
because it's allowing you to step away
from the manual management of Parts your
environment is just going to be
healthier relying on kubernetes to do
the actual management of all the pods
you have out there so you are able to
allow access to from Services outside of
your kubernetes and this is done through
a process called Ingress and going back
earlier we talked about how security is
a key part of all the work that goes
into kubernetes and this is a great
example of where you can use an external
service but still have that layer of
security that is vital for your solution
because to be able to provide the
Ingress connection uh kubernetes
requires an SSL connection which um
automatically allows for a secure data
transfer absolutely fantastic so here we
have an overview of the actual
architecture on the right hand side we
have our nodes and the pods within our
nodes and within those pods are the
containers on the left hand side we have
the master architecture and the master
architecture is the actual brains behind
the work that you're doing it's actually
managing the schedules the controllers
uh for all of the nodes and then at the
bottom left hand side we have commands
which are written on a local workstation
and those commands are pushed up to the
master so let's kind of dig a little bit
further into the architecture of the
master um so the master itself is uh
comprised of a number of key components
um again this is the tool that's going
to manage your uh entire kubernetes
infrastructure the key components that
you have are the uh etcd control manager
scheduler uh API server and the key four
components are etcd uh or the cluster
store the controller manager the
scheduler and the API server the cluster
store is the tool where uh all the
detail of the work that you're doing is
stored it's going to manage the rules
it's going to manage all the
instructions and this is where you're
going to post that information the
controller is actually going to then
perform the tasks that are stored um in
the uh cluster store and as you'd expect
the schedule is the tool that actually
controls when instructions and tasks are
pushed out to um all the pods and nodes
within your network and then finally you
have an API server which allows you to
be able to control all the operations
the actual operations themselves are all
instructions written um as rest
instructions um which allows you to take
advantage of the security that has been
built into rest and so you end up with a
worker slave architecture and slaves are
all the different nodes and pods within
your network and so a pod itself will
have multiple one or more multiple
containers and then each container and
then each pod will have a Docker contain
container uh a kubet and a kubernetes
proxy and the these are tools to allow
you to communicate back up to the master
layer so the docker is the actual
container itself and this is going to
actually run your application and uh the
instructions here are to pull down the
correct container from the docker images
that you have within your library the
cubet is going to manage your containers
and your container instructions that
will be deployed to the cube lit are
going to be written either yam y or Json
format yaml is just great if you haven't
had a chance to start working with yaml
I certainly encourage you to do so it's
very easy to pick up if you know any XML
uh you'll pick up yaml very quickly and
finally the kubernetes proxy is the tool
that interacts with the master
environment within the kubernetes
network and allows all the instructions
from that are pushed to the kuet and to
Docker to be able to perform effectively
so let's have a look at some of the
companies using kubernetes there are a
lot and if you're doing any work today
in the cloud and even if you're just
starting off and doing some um simple
work in the cloud there's a really good
chance that you are using kubernetes but
some of the companies that you would are
probably not surprised are using
kubernetes are uh Spotify sap eBay um
and of course uh some of the uh the big
companies out there Google with their
entire network of solutions and
Microsoft with office and their tools so
let's take a a step into a you now let's
have a look at a kubernetes use case and
in this example we're going to look at
the New York Times and how they use
kubernetes to solve a problem that their
it Department was struggling with so
when New York Times started working
after their data centers there their
actual deployments were small and the
applications were managed across VMS but
the problem is is that as the New York
Times became more of a digital company
they started building more digital
Solutions and at some point they really
realized that what they needed to do was
to embrace the cloud and move all their
solutions to the cloud however their
first step of using the cloud and this
is I think typical for a lot of
companies is that they treated a the
cloud hosted provider in the same way as
they would with a Data Center and they
at some point they realized they had to
take a change and this is where the
development team came in and they said
look how about we stop thinking of our
Solutions as a data center even though
they're being run in Amazon and start
thinking of them as Cloud first
Solutions and so what they proposed and
what they ended up doing was using GL
Google Cloud platform with kubernetes as
service um to provide greater efficiency
and so by using kubernetes they had the
following advantages they're able to
deliver Solutions at a much fastest
speed and in the world of digital
content speed is everything they were
able to reduce the time for deployment
from minutes to seconds and by doing
this they were able to increase the
amount of time that that up time for the
actual uh infrastructure um updates
began to be deployed independently and
when required so you didn't have to
schedule an event when you do the
deployment it just happened and there
was more unified approach to deployment
from the engineering staff which just
made the whole solution more portable so
the fundamental endline for the New York
Times is that by leveraging kubernetes
they were able to automatically manage
their deployments and scheduling of
solutions instead of having to do
Solutions through a more traditional
ticket based system it just really speed
up the efficiency of the New York Times
website so let's finally kind of look
into some of the important terminologies
before we take our time to do a demo so
we have six terms that we're going to
look through um and uh we'll let you uh
read through these but uh uh we have a
cluster which is a set of machines
physical vertical in which applications
are managed and run we have a node that
are the working machines that run
container applications and other
workloads there is the pod which is
within a node and is a group of
containers that are deployed together on
the same host we have replication
controllers and a replication controller
is used to define a pods life cycle
rather than to create the pods directly
we have a selector which is an
expression matched label to filter
specific resources uh labels are key
value pads that are attached to objects
such as parts and the key value pair or
the label can be filter organize and
perform operation on resources
replication SS Define how many replicas
of each pod will be running and managed
when you w want to either replace a pod
when it dies annotation is a label with
much larger data capacity a name is a
resource as it is identified volume is
the directory which data is accessible
to a container name spaces provide
additional qualification to a resources
name and then finally service is an
abstraction of the top tier pods which
provide a single IP address address and
DNS Name by which the pods can be
accessed so at this time what we want to
do is take you through kubernetes demo
and actually runs through some of these
basic controls so we're going to take
you through a video of how to actually
install kubernetes um and to use some of
the basic instructions so kubernetes is
the most wildly used platform for
container management the first step is
to actually install the necessary
dependencies so let's see if there's any
updates first so the first first so to
check if there's any updates we're going
to use the command Pudo app- getet
update we're going enter in our password
and this looks like it's going to take a
few minutes because we've got a few
updates that need to be running all
right we're done all right next we're
going to write PSE sudo app get install
Dy apt-transport-https
and this will install all the
dependencies we need to actually start
installing the solutions needed for
kubernetes all right that was quick now
we're going to to put in the docker
dependency and the way we do that is
write the command sudo app install
docker.io got a typo correct that
quickly and put in y so fors and we
continue and that's going to take a
while because we're going to download
and install Docker off the internet and
it's quite a large installation now it
be a good time to go get a cup of coffee
CU it'll take us about a minute to get
this all done once we actually have
Docker installed we'll actually go ahead
and we'll start Docker and enable Docker
using our pseudo
commands all right so that's all done so
let's start an enable Docker we're going
using so we're going to use pseudo
system CTL start Docker and pseudo
system CTL enable Docker this will be
quite quick so the next step is to
install all the components for
kubernetes and we're going to uh install
the Cur command and then cubet Cube C
and then Cube ADM and we're going to to
install all the necessary tools we do
the co command cubet cubic C2 and Cube
ADM and so let's go ahead and put in the
pseudo ap- get install Cur we're going
to get a prompt we can say yes for that
and then after this we'll go ahead and
install kubernetes so the first what
we're going to do is we're going to
actually put in the kubernetes key so
that's going to be pseudo
c-s and then we have a long URL which is
htps and packages. Cloud goole.com a do
ap- key. gpg pseudo apt-key there we go
cck my typo there okay now we have to go
ahead and change permissions of a folder
so we do that with pseudo
chmod
etap sources.list DOD all right we're
good okay now you want to go ahead and
open up your text editor and we're going
to make um an actual edit um we're going
create a simple file and so what we're
going to type in is um the F command DB
htbt a-. kubernetes doio kubernetes dzal
Main and we're going to save this file
in the ETC folder and then look for and
then a AP which is going to be down a
little bit and there we have it and
we're going to save it in the
apt-get updates and we're going to name
this file as kubernetes do list and
we'll save that and then we can close
out the notepad and go back to the
terminal window and let's look and see
if there are any updates again so we're
going to go ahead and run apt-get update
and it's going to run any updates from
what we've created and we want to check
what's in the folder and so we can do
cat ET Etc apt sources. this . dcnet es.
list and there we are it shows what we
have in that text file and so we're
going to go ahead and we're going to uh
install uh cubet cubic cubic 2 and C ADM
but first we're going to have to
initialize the master I'm going to show
you what an error you would get if you
were to install cuet um and the other
files too quickly you get the following
error all right so so we have installed
cubet QB ADM cual and kubernetes cni and
so we're going to go ahead and use
pseudo swap
up-- a and now we're going to initialize
the M node and we're going to do that
with pseudo Cube ADM in it and this will
take a few minutes for it to
initialize all right so that's all done
all right so we're going to deploy the
Pod to a network and we have two
commands that we're going to use we use
pseudo cubu Cube CTL apply and then we
have a a long path we have to type out
which is-f htbs raw github's content.com
coros flannel Master documentation Cube
flannel do
yml what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're going to do that by
creating um mkdr DP and then we have p
dollar sign home- Dobe we'll create that
new directory and pseudo
cp-i and then the path will be uh Etc
dcnet admin. NF and then dollar sign
home.be doc
config and then final one will
be pseudo CH WN doll sign open PR
id- close PR colon on dollar sign open
PR ID DG close PR doll sign
home.be SL config all right now we're
going to go ahead and uh deploy and uh
let's see oh I think I have a typo in my
command here yep oh yeah I did have a
typo and so um I've got that incorrect
now so documentation is actually spelled
with a t not an S and then we're going
to go ahead and we're going to put in
the next line which is
cubic Cube CTL apply do- F and then
we're just going to change a little bit
of the um actual link here and that runs
great and now we want to be able to see
all of the uh pods that we have in our
Network and so we're going to do that by
writing the command pseudo cuc TCL uh
get pods Das all do- name spaces and it
should list all of our pods we only have
one
there we are there's all of our content
now we're going do so there's only one
node so let's see what we have here so
we're going to use command sudo qxl get
nodes there we are just one node so our
final step is to actually go ahead and
deploy a service and so what we're going
to go ahead is deploy the ngx service
and we're going to do that with the
command pseudo cuex CTL run D- image
equals ngx and we're going to put this
into port 80 so it's going to be ngx D
app-- Port equal 80 D- environment EMV
equals uh open col open quotes domain
equals cluster close
quotes and we're going to write one more
command which is Pudo Cube CTL expose
deployment nx- app-- portal 80 D- name
equals ngx D HTTP and once we've done
this we'll be able to then run the
command to actually see us services and
there'll be quite a few of
them and our final command is pseudo
Docker ps-
a we are quite a lot of list quite a lot
of services listed so there you are
that's the instructions on how to get
Docker up and running and uh with some
basic commands um it is worth going
through a few times to um get right um
but uh once you actually have um the
kubernetes environment up and running
and managing your do environment
containers it's extremely powerful if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more welcome to kubernetes
architecture from Simply learn we're
going to take a deep dive into the
kubernetes architecture if you're new to
kubernetes we already have an
introduction that goes and provides an
overview of kubernetes and we have the
link below so you can go straight to
that if you want to have a refresher
otherwise hang around and and join us in
this presentation and if you want to see
more of these videos hit the Subscribe
button and if you want to get notified
hit the notification Bell and every time
we post up a new video you'll get the
notification right onto your phone or on
your desktop that the new video has been
uploaded and as always if you have any
questions please post them in the
comments below we do read the questions
and we try to respond to all of them as
quickly as we can with that said let's
jump into kubernetes architecture so
we're going to break out the
presentation to the following areas
we're going to cover what is and why you
want to be using it we're going to
introduce the actual architecture and
provide an overview of how it contains
the containers and the other components
that you'd have within the architecture
will also compare cetes with Docker
swarm and one of the things that you
hear with kubernetes is almost in the
same um breath as Docker and we have to
be careful not to confuse Docker from a
container point of view and Docker swarm
which is a container management tool and
kubernetes is also a container
management tool so we compare the two of
those and then we'll look at the
hardware and software components and
then finally do a deep dive into the
architecture of kubernetes and provide a
case study of where kubernetes has been
used successfully in the past so let's
jump into this so what actually is
kubernetes so kubernetes is a tool that
was designed to actually help manage and
contain large groups of containers it
was developed originally uh by Google
out of the Google Bor um solution and
then Open Source by Google the actual
environment allows you to and manage
large groups of containers so if you're
a developer in devops and you're working
with Docker then you're used to the
concept of a container and uh you'll
also know that containers and Cloud
Technologies tend to be almost breathed
in the same breath so the work that
you're doing with kubernetes is to be
able to manage large groups of
containers inside of the cloud the thing
that's great about working with
kubernetes is that it is incredibly
flexible and allows you to have
incredibly complex application run
efficient efficiently so let's step into
why you'd want to use kubernetes so a
couple of key points kubernetes itself
is an open- Source solution originally
developed by Google but it is available
on most Cloud platforms today so AWS
Google Cloud Microsoft Azure all of them
support kubernetes and what you'll find
is as you're setting up your
infrastructure particularly if you're
using containers you'll see that the
support for kubernetes is floated up
very very efficiently and effectively by
all three vendors it's extremely um
useful for being able to manage large
modular environments and that's really
kind of the I think one of the big
benefits of kubernetes is its modularity
is that it really breaks down uh
containers into their smaller parts and
once you do that it becomes much more
efficient uh for you as an administrator
to be able to manage that en entire
environment the reproductibility of
kubernetes is extremely high uh you can
build out infrastructures very quickly
and um have them being able to Manch and
um have containers coming on and off um
killed and created to be able to help
load balance your entire environment and
so again you we keep talking about
containers but that's really what
kubernetes is all about it's being able
to manage your applications that are
managed through containers and being
able to do that in a virtualized
infrastructure and the thing that's also
really good with kubernetes is it's
really easy to too Solutions you just
have to use a simple Co call and you can
actually push out your C kubernetes
infrastructure so let's have an overview
of the kubernetes architecture so
kubernetes is really broken up into
three key areas so you have your
workstation where you develop your
commands and you push out those commands
to your master and the master is
comprised of um four key areas um which
essentially control all of your nodes
and and the node contains multiple pods
and each pod has your Docker container
built into it so consider that you could
have a really almost an infinite number
of PODS sorry infinite number number of
nodes being managed um by the master
environment so you have your cluster
which is a collection of servers that
maintain the Ava availability and the
compute power such as RAM CPU and disk
utilization um you have the master which
is really component that control and
schedule uh the activities of your
network and then you have the node which
actually hosts the actual Docker virtual
machine itself um and be able to
actually control and communicate back to
the master the health of of that part
and we'll get into more detail on the
architecture later in the presentation
so you know you keep hearing me talk
about um containers but they really are
the center of the work that you're doing
with kubernetes and the concept around
kubernetes and containers is really just
a natural evolution of where we've been
with internet and digital Technologies
over the last uh 10 15 years so before
kubernetes um you had tools where where
you're either running virtual machines
or you're running uh data centers that
had to maintain and and manage and
notify of any interruptions in your
network kubernetes is the tool that
actually comes in and helps address
those interruptions and manages them for
you so the solution to this is the use
of containers so uh you can think of
containers as that Natural Evolution
from you know uh 15 20 years ago you
would have written your code and posted
it to a data center uh more recently you
probably posted your code to a virtual
machine and then move the virtual
machine and now you actually just work
directly into a container and everything
is self-contained and can be pushed out
to your um environment and the thing
that's great about containers they're
they're isolated environments very easy
for developers to work in them but it's
also really easy for uh operations teams
to be able to move a container into
production so let's kind of step and
back and look at a competing product to
kubernetes which is Docker swarm now one
of the things that we have to um
remember is that Docker um containers
which are extremely popular um built by
the company Docker and made open source
and Docker actually has other products
one of those other products uh is Docker
swarm and Docker swarm is a tool that
allows you to be able to manage multiple
containers uh so if we look at some of
the uh the benefits of using Docker
swarm versus kubernetes and one of the
things that you'll find is that both
tools have strength and weakness es but
it's really good that they're both out
there because it helps keep it really
kind of justifies uh the importance of
having these kind of tools so kubernetes
was designed originally from the ground
up to be autoscaling whereas Ducker
swarm isn't the load balancing is
automatic on Docker Swan whereas with
kubernetes you have to manually
configure load balancing across your
nodes the installation for dock swarm is
really fast and easy I mean you can be
up and running within minutes I could
kubernetes takes a little bit more time
is a little bit more complicated
eventually you'll get there um I mean
it's not like it's going to take you
days and weeks but it's it is a tool
that's a when you compare the two dror
swarm's much easier to get up and
running now what's interesting is that
kubernetes is incredibly scalable and
it's you know that's its real strength
is its ability to have strong clusters
whereas with Docker swarm it's cluster
strength isn't um as strong when
compared to kubernetes now you compare
it to anything else on the market it's
really good um so this is kind of a
splitting hairs kind of comparison um
but kubernetes really does have the
advantage here if you're looking at the
two compared to each other for
scalability I mean kubernetes was
designed for by Google to scale up and
support uh Google Cloud Network
infrastructure they uh both allow you to
be able to share um storage volumes with
do you can actually do it um with um any
container U with u that is managed by
the docker swamp whereas with kubernetes
it manages is the storage with the pods
and a pod can have multiple containers
within it but you can't take it down to
the level of the container interestingly
uh kubernetes does have a graphical user
interface um for being able to control
and manage uh the environment the
reality however is that you're likely to
be using terminal uh to actually make
the controls and Commands to control
your um either Docker swarm or
kubernetes environment um it's great
that it has a a gooey and to get you
started but once you're up and running
you're going to be using terminal window
for those fast quick administrative
controls that you need to make so let's
look at the hardware components for
kubernetes so um what's interesting is
that kubernetes is extremely light of
all the systems that we're looking at
it's extremely lightweight um it's
allows you to have if you compare it to
like a virtual machine which is very
heavy you know um cumes is extremely
lightweight and hardly uses any
resources at all interesting enough
though is that if you are looking at the
usage of CPU it's it's better to
actually take it for um uh the cluster
as a whole rather than individual nodes
uh because uh the nodes will actually
combine together to give you that whole
compute power again this is why
kubernetes works really well in the
cloud where you can do that kind of
activity rather than if you're running
in your own data center um so you can
have persistent volumes um such as a
local SSD um or you can actually attach
to a cloud data storage again kubernetes
is really designed for the cloud I would
encourage you to use cloud storage
wherever possible rather than relying on
physical storage uh the reason being is
that if you connect to cloud storage and
you need to flex your your storage the
cloud will do that for you I mean that's
just an inherent part of why you would
have cloud storage whereas if you're
connecting to physical storage you're
always restricted to the limitations of
the physical Hardware so let's um kind
of pivot and look at the software
components as compared to to the
hardware components so the main part of
the components is the actual container
and all of the software running in the
container runs on Linux so if you um
have Docker installed as a developer on
your machine it's actually running
inside of Linux um that's what makes it
so lightweight and really one of the
things that you'll find is that most
data centers and Cloud providers now are
running predominantly on Linux inside of
the um the the container itself is then
managed inside of a p and a part is
really just a group of containers
bundled together and um the kubernetes
scheduler and proxy Ser then actually
manage what um how the pods are actually
pushed out uh into your kubernetes
environment the the pods themselves can
actually then share resources both
networking and storage so pods aren't um
pushed out manually they're actually um
managed through a layer of abstraction
and part of their deployment and and
this is the strength of kubernetes you
you use um def find your um
infrastructure and then kubernetes will
then manage it for you and there isn't
that problem of um manual management of
PODS uh if you have to manage the
deployment of them and you that's simply
taken away and it's completely automated
and the the final area of software
Services is on Ingress and this is
really the secure way of being able to
have communication from outside of the
cluster and passing of information into
that cluster um and again this is done
securely through SSL layers and allows
you to ensure that security is at the
center of the work that you have within
your kubernetes environment so let's
dive now into the actual architecture
before we start looking at a use case of
how kubernetes is being employed so
kubernetes again is um we looked at this
uh diagram at the beginning of the
presentation and there are really three
key areas there's the workstation where
you develop your commands and then you
have your master environment which uh
controls the uh scheduling the commun
communication um and the actual um
commands that you have created and
pushes those out and manages the health
of your entire node Network and each
node has uh various pods so we like
break this down uh so the master node is
the most vital component um with the
master uh you have four key controls you
have Etc controller manager schedule and
API server the cluster store Etc this
actually manes the details and vales
that you've developed on your local
workstation um and then we'll work with
the out the control schedule on API
server to communicate that out those
instructions of how your infrastructure
should look like to your entire network
uh the control manager is really an API
server and again um this is all about
security so we use restful fpis um which
can be packaged in SSL to communicate
back and forth um across your uh pods
and the master and indeed the services
within each of them as well so um at
every single layer of extraction uh the
communication is secure uh the schedule
as the name would imply really schedules
um when tasks get sent out to the actual
nodes themselves the nodes themselves
are are dumb nodes they just have uh the
applications um running on them the
master and the um is really doing all of
the work uh to make sure that your
entire network is running um efficiently
and then you have the API server which
has your res commands and the
communication um back of forth across
your network that is secure and
efficient so your node environment is
where all the work that you do with your
containers gets pushed out too so um a a
work is really a it's a combination of
containers and each container will then
logically run together on that node so
you'd have a collection of containers uh
on a node that all make logical sense to
have together uh within each node um you
have a Docker and this is your isolated
environment for running your container
uh you have your cubet which is a
service for conveying information back
and forth um to the service about the
actual health of the kubernetes node
itself and then finally you have the
proxy server and the proxy server is
able to manage the nodes the volumes the
the creation of new containers um and
actually helps pass the communic the the
health of the container back up to the
master to see whether or not the
container should be either killed stop
started or um updated so finally let's
look at see where uh kubernetes is being
used by other companies so you know
kubernetes is being used by a lot of
companies and they're really using it to
help manage complex existing systems so
that they can have uh greater
performance and with the end goal of
being able to Delight the customer and
increase value to the customer and hence
increase value and revenue into the
organization so an example of this is a
company called Black Rock uh where they
actually went through the process of
implementing kubernetes uh so they so
Black Rock had a chance where they
needed to be able to have much more
Dynamic access to their resources uh
they were running complex installations
on people's desktops and it was just
really really difficult to be able to
manage their entire infrastructure and
so they actually went um pivoted to
using cetes and this allowed them to be
able to be much more scalable and
expansive in the management of their uh
infrastructure and as you can imagine
kubernetes was then hooked into their
entire existing system system and has
really become a key part of the success
that Black Rock is now experiencing of a
very stable infrastructure um and the
bottom line is that U Black Rock is now
able to have confidence in their
infrastructure and be able to give that
confidence um as back to their customers
through the implementation and more
rapid deployment of additional features
and services kubernetes specific to AWS
Cloud platform so what's a part of this
tutorial and demo what's in store for
you at of offset I would I would like to
cover the basics of orchestration tools
as most of you would know kubernetes is
one of the most popular orchestration
tools in recent times specifically for
applications which are Cloud native and
deployed on some or the other types of
containers but what are these
orchestration tools why would one need
to use orchestration tools what are the
facilities or features provided by these
orchestration tools that's the first
thing that I'm going to cover after that
I will pick two orchestration tools
specific to container man management do
swarm versus kubes I'm going to compare
them with regard to the features that
they provide the use cases that they
cover what facilities that they provide
and when to use what after that I will
get into a little bit details of the
kuet architecture what exactly is
required for setting up a kues cluster
what runs in a control plane or a master
node what runs as a part of the worker
node after that I will end the tutorial
by running you through a demo by setting
up a three node kubernetes cluster on
AWS platform I will use something called
as cops which is one of the admin tools
for setting a production grade KUB disc
cluster so I will use this to set up a
three note cluster on AWS all right now
that we set the context right let me get
started so what are orchestration tools
the application development and the life
cycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has the requirement
that it has in terms of the hardware the
features of fa tolerance self-healing
capabilities Auto scaling all this has
complicated over the last few years as a
part of devops one thing that everyone
is interested in is managing all this
application dependency or life cycle
management using some or the other kind
of a tool so that's where these
orchestration tools have become very
very popular so what kind of features
that they provide is you'll have to just
let them know what are the kinds of tool
sets that is required what are the fall
tolerance mechanisms that it has to be
adopted to what kind of a selfhealing
capabilities that application will have
to need and if at all there is any
autoscaling features that is required if
at all you can bake in all these
specific parameters into your tool your
orch ation tool becomes a One-Stop shop
for all your deployment and
configuration management needs that's
where this orchestration tools have
become very very popular and relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more uh interested in adopting
devops practices all right so having
said that about orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools specifically for
container management Docker swarm and
kubernetes many of the application s
that are written for these kind of
containers are called or kind of fall
into a category of cloud native where
the application need not know much about
the underlying infrastructure or the
platform where these applications are
running so these two along with Apache
misos there are many other container
Management systems but I'm going to pick
Docker swarm and kubernetes for
comparing the features that is provided
by these two Frameworks for the sake of
comparison I picked up Doos swarm and
kues just because of the reason that
both of them operate in the space of
container management they do something
very very similar to Containers that's
the similarity that exists between these
two orchestration tools however there's
a big difference that exist when it
comes to the types of containers that
both of them cater to and also the
capacity of workloads they can be used
for Docker swarm is a cluster management
solution that is provided by Docker
container docker is one of the very very
popular containers of recent times and
in case you have your applications that
is totally powered by only Docker
containers if you have a need where you
want to run a cluster of servers which
are running only Docker containers
Docker swarm should be your choice for
your orchestration tool kubernetes on
the other hand can cater to any other
types of containers other than Docker
and including Docker as well so in case
you have your applications which have
got Docker in them which have got rkt in
them which they have got LX in them or
any other type of container kubis should
be your choice of orchestration too a
Docker swarm can manage up to 40 50 or
60 Max uh nodes so in case your
application is totally written in Docker
containers and the load or the expected
cluster size is around 50 60 notes
Docker swamp should be your choice of
orchestration tool on the other hand
kubernetes is something that was open
sourced by Google and the kind of the
scale of operations that kubernetes can
cater to is Google scale so if in case
your applications are more than a
thousand nodes that is where kubernetes
comes into play that's the big
difference that exists between doas
swarm and kubernetes putting those
differences aside let me compare Doos
swarm and kubernetes based upon other
features which are similar in nature the
first and important feature that
kubernetes provides is something called
as autoscaling if at all the load on
your cluster is too high and your
application is experiencing more load so
kubernetes can add new nodes to your
cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new VMS or new nodes if at all you do
that configuration correctly kubernetes
has got the capacity or it has got the
feature where it can bring up a new node
and add it to the cluster on the Fly
based upon the load that exist at that
moment on similar lines if at all the
load is not too high it can identify few
of those nodes which have got less
number of uh replicas or less number of
application containers running on it it
can move them to some other node and
also scal down by deleting few nodes
from your cluster so that is the
powerfulness of autoscaling which is
provided by Ces and this unfortunately
does not exist in Docker swamp the other
feature of load balance
specifically application load balancing
so dock swarm gives you an application
Level autoload balancing however
kubernetes gives you the flexibility of
manually configuring any other type of
load balancer of your choice for
application load balancing installation
as I mentioned earlier Docker swarm is a
loose cluster of containers which are
running on nodes it is very easy to spin
up a new node and then connect them to a
swarm and this can be done in a very
very lose coupled way where you can
create swamps of your choice notes are
are allowed to connect to swamps and
quit or leave the swamps on the fly so
in and all the installation is pretty
easy and fast kubernetes on the other
hand the configuration of kubernetes the
way to spin up a big cluster specifying
the size of the node how many Master
nodes how many config planes that you
want how many nodes that you want it's a
pretty tough thing to bring up a
kubernetes scalability kubernetes
strength is very very strong they are
very tightly coupled and even they have
the capability where on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the Fly based upon the requirement on a
doer swarm the cluster strength is weak
as compared to kues worker nodes can be
added to a swarm worker noes can be
asked to leave a swarm or can be taken
out of a swarm based upon the
requirement so this is kind of a Loosely
coupled architecture for Doos swarm
while KU is the cluster is very tightly
coupled since Doos swarm runs only
Docker containers containers find it
very easy to share data and a lot of
other things with each other because
they all have the same signature they're
all from the same family so it's very
easy for them to share not just volumes
but a lot of other things however for
kuber is since it manages containers of
different types if your application has
to share some data across different
containers there little bit of a
complexity in how you would want your
containers to share data also uh when it
comes to kubernetes kubernetes groups
containers in something called as pods
while a pod can have either one
container that's the preferred choice or
multiple containers and the idea of pod
is like each pod can run in any other
node it's not guaranteed that you would
want to have two or three pods to be
running on the same node that makes data
sharing a little bit of a different
thing compared to doas form uh GUI so
this not a good enough uh UI tool in
Dockers form at least uh the C edition
of it which which will allow you to get
to know what is running on your
containers what is the size of the
containers what is the volume of the
containers and all that stuff there are
some free and open source tools like
painer which gives you a good visibility
into your running Docker containers
however there's nothing at a swarm level
that is provided by Docker kubernetes
gives you an outof the-box dashboard
which is easy to configure and set up
you can also Club it with some metrics
services and you can also get
information about the size of the
cluster that is running what is the load
on the nodes and stuff like that all
this across your cluster in a very
beautiful dashboard perspective so that
way um this is little bit of a good UI
for kubernetes while for Docker form
there isn't anything that is provided
out of the box let me spend some time in
explaining a little bit about the kuis
architecture what comprises of the kuber
cluster what resides in a master or a
control plane and what resides in a work
node this is a very high level uh
depiction of a communties cluster so
this is the master node which has got
something called as a cluster store a
controller a schedular component and an
API server and these are the bunch of
nodes that are connected or administered
by the master node the master node can
be 1 3 5 typically an odd number this is
as per the typical cluster management
thing where you would need the master
nodes to be in odd numbers so that
whenever there's any contention in terms
of what needs to be deployed where or
where to give the job to whom and stuff
like that all the Masters would cast
their wot and they would decide on the
outcome so that's the master node and
there are a bunch of uh nodes which can
be connected and administered by the
master node qctl or the command from
using which anybody can assign some
workloads to the cluster can also be run
either on the same node or on a separate
node so qctl is is the command line tool
that we will be installing and using in
order to fire up our commands to our
cluster so if at all I have to put up a
job on our cluster if I have to give out
any specific commands to my cluster all
this is done using ql there's a bunch of
rest apis which is used by ql and ql
will talk to the API server and fire up
the commands specific to my cluster what
runs in the master node Master node
without seeing it's the most important
component of any of the cluster if at
all you're running um cluster with only
one master node if your master node goes
down there's no other way that you know
you can or any user can talk to the
different nodes in the cluster so Master
node is the most vital component
responsible for the complete kubernetes
cluster there's always one node that
should be running as a master node
that's the bare minimal requirement for
your cluster so what are the other
components in the master node the most
important one is called etcd so this is
nothing but a data store a value of key
value pair which is stored which
contains all information about your
cluster so all the configuration details
which uh node is up which worker node is
down all this information is stored in
the cluster store so all the managers
would access this cluster store before
they go ahead and decide any other work
item or anything else that has to be
done specific to your cluster what's in
the controller as the name says
controller is something it's like a
demon server that is running in a
continuous loop all the time it is
responsible for controlling the set of
replicas the kind of uh workloads that
is running based upon the configuration
that the user has set in so if at all if
you are aware of something called as
replication controllers endpoint
controllers namespace controllers all
these controllers are managed by the
controller component if any user asked
for some three replicas of a particular
pod or a service to be running and if at
all any of the nodes goes down or the
Pod goes down for whatsoever reason the
controller is the one who wakes up and
assigns this particular job or the part
to some other available node by looking
up for the details using in the cluster
store that's the importance of the
control manager or the controller the
scheduler the scheduler assigns the task
based upon whoever is asked for any job
to be scheduled based upon a time frame
or based upon some criteria it also
tracks the working load as to what what
exactly is the load who is running What
in in the cluster and places the
workload on whoever is the available
resource at that time all right API
server this is one other important
component in in our kubernetes cluster
where how would the end user deploy or
give out any sort of a workload onto
your cluster all the requests come to
the API server so this is an entry point
for all all your um requests that come
into your cluster anybody wants to
deploy something anybody wants to scale
up a controller anybody wants to bring
down few Services anybody wants to put
in a service all this will have to come
in as a part of a rest um API endpoint
and API server is the entry point in
case you don't want uh you know somebody
to access your cluster in case you want
only specific people or a specific users
to be running some specific workloads
you can set all those role based access
control for this API server so this is
the entry point for anyone who wants to
submit any job to your cluster so that's
a quick overview about the master node
what what are the important components
of a master node now let's go over to
what runs in a worker or a slave node as
I mentioned earlier slave nodes are
something where the job that is
submitted to your cluster is eventually
run as a pod as a service as a container
so in kues world there's something
called as a pod a pod is nothing but a
combination of a container it is a
wrapper around your running containers
so slave nodes or the worker nodes
typically run these parts so that is
where the whole workload typically gets
run but there are a bunch of other
components in the in the node which also
manages what runs in the Pod who has to
have access to the Pod what is the state
of the Pod is it in a running state is
it going down for some reason and all
that stuff so let's quick ly go over
those components that is there in the
slim node the most important component
in my opinion that should be on the on
the Node should be the container run
time as I mentioned earlier kuties can
run any different types of containers
not just Docker so in case you want to
have a node which wants to have Docker
running on it RK running on it LKC
running on it or any other uh container
environment that is running on it you
have to ensure that the specific
container runtime environment is
available on that specific node so that
whenever a job is submitted a
description of what needs to be run as a
part of the Pod what should be the image
with with it should be powered and what
kind of a container to spin up so that's
what you know when the job is finally
assigned to this particular node it
would definitely need a container
runtime to be up and running so that
exists only if at all the container
runtime is installed and running on your
kubernetes worker note okay now that we
know what our kubernetes node can run
how would somebody assign a job to our
node that is using something called as a
cubet as the name says cubet or cubet is
a small subset which talks to the cube
API server so any node which has to run
any kind of a pod all these instructions
are passed around by the qbp server to
the cuet and cuet is capable of
processing whatever job that is assign
to it and ensuring that so many parts
and so many services are spun up based
upon the requirement the last component
that exist uh in the worker node is the
cube proxy or kubernetes proxy this
plays a very very important role acting
as a load balancer and a network proxy
so what typically happens is whenever
the pods are running in nodes the parts
can be typically running in any node
there is no um a Affinity towards any
node on which these parts are running
because pods or containers are something
called as ephemeral they can run
anywhere so how would somebody reach out
to these applications that is running on
some pod which is running in one
container now and running in probably
another container another node
altogether tomorrow so that is where
your kubernetes proxy com into picture
and this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any pod
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these SPS and kind of connects the end
points or acts like a DNS server so that
it knows when somebody is trying to
reach out to this particular service
which is the pod on which the service is
typically running so that plays a very
very important role by acting as a load
balancer and a network proxy now that at
a very high level we know what are all
the components that make up of our
kubernetes cluster let's go ahead and
create a small cluster we'll spin up
this cluster on AWS platform finally we
get to the demo section of my tutorial
now that you guys are aware as to what
is kubernetes what is the use of
kubernetes you also know at a very very
high level what are the components of a
cluster what is a master node or a
control plane what are the components of
a master node and what should be
existing in a worker node you probably
thinking that it's going be pretty hard
to kind of set this up so let me
demystify that by running you with a
quick demo of how to set up a simple
three node Kubin dis cluster using a
tool called cops and I will be doing
this whole setup on my AWS Cloud okay so
what is cops cops is nothing but a
simple tool this is an admin tool that
allows you to bring up production grade
uh kubernetes environments as I said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is little challenging so that
is why I would use something called as a
cops and I will use this on my cluster
uh which I will spin up on my AWS
instance so I have an AWS account and
what I'll do first is I will first spin
up an ec2 server I will power this with
one of the um Linux Amis and I will
install cops on it now this will be my
starting point from where I'm going to
trigger running up a big cluster in our
case I'll try to keep it little small I
don't want too many nodes in my cluster
I'm going to have one master node and
two worker nodes this whole operation
would be done programmatically by
installing this cops uh admin tool so as
you may know AWS it's little hard for me
to programmatically run other components
or rather bring up servers it's not
pretty simple so what I will do is I
will create an IM am rule which will
attach to my ec2 server so that my ec2
server gets powered uh with all the
required rule so that it can go ahead
and spin up cluster based upon my
configuration that I'm going to specify
all right so once I have my cluster set
up I will also install qctl which uh you
would probably know by now is nothing
but a command line utility using which I
can kind of connect to my cluster give
out some jobs put some pots and stuff
like that so I will use ql I will also
have a pair of SSH keys so that from
this machine I would be able to
successfully get onto the master node
and submit jobs on my behalf so let me
Begin by first logging into my AWS
account all the steps that I will be
following to bring up my AWS cluster
kubernetes cluster will be documented
and I'll be sharing you this document in
a GitHub repository so that in case
anybody wants to try you'll be more than
happy to find all the required
instructions in one place okay now the
first thing that I would need is to
launch an AWS ec2 instance now this is
an instance where I'm going to install
cops and I will use it as a base server
from where I'm going to fire some
commands which will bring up my kues
cluster so let me log into my AWS
account and um let me stick to one
particular region and let me bring up
some a one ec2 instance all right so let
me launch my instance let me choose um
doesn't matter either ways but in case
you want to try it on your free tire I
would recommend choose free tire only
and choose an Ami of your choice let me
choose this instance I will make it T2
micro that is good for me configuration
instance details all right I don't want
to change anything here that looks good
maybe I will change this 30 gig that's
good for me let me add a tag to my
instance I will name this as my cops
server all right I would need a bunch of
of boats to be opened up so what I will
do is I create a new Security Group uh
called open to the word I would not
recommend that you do this since I don't
want to it'll take a long time for me to
specifically uh pick and choose um the
ports that has to be open for running my
cluster I don't want to do that I will
open up all the uh HTTP and https ports
so that it's quicker so I will say all
TCP I would say from anywhere just to be
on the safest side of also open HTTP and
https and I will make this anywhere and
anywhere this is good for me I will say
review and launch all right so I chose a
T2 micro instance just for the sake of
easiness I opened up all the ports and
um the instant details are you've seen
what is that I've chosen all right now
important part is like I would need a
Keir I need to create a new Keir I will
call this as simply learn keys I will
download this keare and then I will
launch the instance it'll take some time
for my acc2 instance to come up in the
meanwhile what I'll do is I will convert
I have this pem file which is the pair
of keys the SSH keys with which I need
to log into my E2 instance so I'll need
to convert this because I'm trying to
connect from a Windows box I would need
to convert this into a PPK file so I
have put gen I'm going to load my set of
keys here and convert that key into a
PPK key all right open all right I would
say save hang on save Private key yes I
would say simply learn or simply learn
private private key I save this here
done that that's all so this is my
public key which is the pem file and
this is my PPK or my private key Now
using the private key I will log into my
ec2 instance okay now my E2 instance is
up and running it is running in this uh
Ohio region and this is the IP address
of my public IP address of my machine so
let me connect to it so I use uh MOBA
xterm which is nothing but an SSH
emulator you can use puty or any of
these sessions uh which allow you to do
an SSH uh this is my IP address of my
machine and uh since I've spun up an
Amazon Ami the user this is the default
user I would need to specify the private
keys for my session and this is the
private key for my session say okay I am
in my uh Amazon E2 instance so let me
look at what are the other things that I
need to do all right so as I said I just
brought up my E2 instance but I would
need my ec2 instance to run few things
on my behalf so that it can spin up ec2
other E2 instances it can also talk to
an S3 bucket where I'm going to store
the instance state of my kuet cluster
also some sort of an autoscaling group
because I want to spin up more and more
instances I also want to have a private
hosted Zone using using my Route 53 so I
would need my E2 instance to have all
these sort of permissions for my server
so what I would do is I will go and
create a permission a rule in the ec2
rather in the AWS IM Rule and I will
attach this IM rule to my e to instance
all right so let me go to my IM am which
is nothing but the identity and uh
access management I'll will create a
role called as possibly cops role I will
create a role this role will be used by
my ec2 so I'm going to click on ec2 and
will say next permissions they would
need a lot of permissions uh specific
permissions to be very honest and the
permissions are all listed out here S3
ec2 and all this stuff just to keep it
pretty simple what I would do is I
create a role with the administrative
access all right so I don't want any
tags I will review I'll create a role
name I will say cops roll for E2 all
right so I'm going to create a role
which has got administrative access rle
so I'm going to create a role so this
would ensure that my my ec2 instance
from which I'm going to run my cluster
would have all the prerequisite
permission so that it can go and spin up
instances talk to S3 buckets and all
that stuff all right now let us have our
running instance get powered by this Ro
so I will connect this role to my
running instance all right so this is my
um EC to instant that is running I'll
say action attach attach attach attach
replace IM am roles so there is no role
as of now I would want my cops Ro for
this is the role that I created so I
want this new rule to be assigned to my
ec2 all right great now my ec2 instance
which is my cop server has got all the
required permissions so that he can
create a cluster on my behalf great now
before this let me do a sudo yum update
hphone y so that any of the because this
is a newly provisioned VM I just want to
ensure that all my library system
libraries are all updated so that when I
do install cop and cctl and all those
things none of them will fail because of
some dependency or package issues so I'm
just running a Pudo update iPhone y so
that all the libraries are updated okay
looks like it is done so let me go ahead
and uh install cops cops is a pretty
simple installation it is available in a
particular location I have to just copy
this and ensure that I do a curl and I
install this particular stuff all right
so it is fetching uh the cops tool it's
installing for me once it is copied down
let me change the mode so that I can
execute it and then also let me move it
to my user local bin so that it is
available for me in my path okay that's
pretty much the cops installation let me
also do one other thing let me install
something called as qctl so this is what
would be you know a tool using which I'm
going to be firing my uh commands to my
cubis cluster once it comes up okay this
is a pretty smaller executable so cctl
all right so I have Cub CTL as well as
cops installed on my easy to server now
okay now what I'll do next is I'm going
to create an S3 bucket in AWS so that
the kues uh cluster state is persisted
in this bucket so let me create a simple
bucket with this name S3 bucket with
this name so let me go to S3 and uh let
me create a simple bucket with this name
I will just say create a bucket okay so
the simply learn. kubernetes is the
bucket that I created so this bucket
will store all information about my
cluster let me now uh go and create a
DNS entry or a DNS zone or AWS Route 53
hostage zone for my cluster so this is
required so that you know I can give a
cluster name for my communties cluster
that I'm coming up so I will create a
private hostage Zone and possi possibly
I will call this as um simply learn. in
so this will be my name of my private
hostage Zone in case you already have
any other uh public hostage zones in
your name you can always is put a Route
53 hostage Zone specific for your domain
name since I don't have anyone I'm just
going to create a simple private hostage
zone so let me head down to Route uh 53
click on any of these and you'll get
these hosted zones out here so I'm going
to create a hostage Zone here I'm going
to create a hostage Zone click on create
hostage Zone um this would be simply
learn. in I want to create a public no I
don't want public I want a private
hostage Zone and I'm going to associate
my VPC ID uh for this hostage Zone since
I'm going to try out all my exercises in
the Ohio region I will associate the VPC
of the Ohio region for this all right so
this is the one uh that is specific to
the Ohio region so I will say this one
I'll say create hostage Z great now let
me come back to my ec2 box my ec2 is all
powered with whatever it needs in order
to uh go ahead with the installation of
my cluster only few things that I need
to take care of is that you know now
that I put a name for my cluster I also
have an uh S3 bucket that I configured
for my cluster I will have to ensure
that I need to put in these two
configurations as a part of my uh
cluster building activity so I will open
my uh bash RC file and I'm going to
export these two variables if at all you
remember well uh these two variables are
nothing but the cluster name which is
nothing but the public sorry the private
hosted Zone that I created and the S3
bucket where I'm going to create or
rather I'm going to store my cluster
state so let me copy these two and open
up my bash RC file all right so I will
just add these two I'll copy these and
Export them out as my uh variable I'm
going to save this here now let me
ensure that this gets picked up all
right I've got these two that I've
configured and I also ensure that these
environment variables are set now let me
create a pair of SSH keys this is to
ensure that I can log into the box that
I'm going to be provisioning as a part
of my cluster SS s hyphen keyen I don't
want to give any parameters let it go to
the home directory with the default uh
name and without any passphrase all
right so I created a bunch of my keypad
now I'm all set to go ahead and run my
cops now cops will ensure that this will
take some time for the cluster to come
up but this is exactly how I would
Define my cops command I already copied
here so cops create cluster the state of
the cluster will be stored in this
particular variable which is what I have
EXP ported out the number of note count
is two note count is the worker note
count if at all I don't spec there's an
configuration for specifying the master
or the control p as well if I don't
specify that the default one is one so
I'm going to create one primary or the
master node and two uh worker nodes uh
size of my master not size of the worker
nodes uh what are the zones where I want
uh these to be created and where do I
store the cluster information and uh
okay I've already added this master
account this is actually not requ
required but this is the command that
I'm going to fire off so that I bring up
my cluster all right that went off um
very fast but um this actually did not
create a cluster it is just the
definition of a cluster and uh that's
why this came out very fast now that
everything looks good with uh whatever
configuration that I specified now let
me go ahead and create the cluster by
saying cops update cluster iph iPhone 8
yes now this will take some time a good
5 to 10 minutes for it to because this
will actually start provisioning the
servers and as I mentioned earlier based
upon my configuration I'm going to come
up with one master server and uh two
nodes or the worker nodes all right so
this is the command for me to validate
the cluster and I'm want to try it out
first I'm pretty sure that it'll fail
because all my servers are not up yet it
is taking some time with the validation
everything failed but let me try to look
at my ec2 instances and um see how many
servers do I have running as of now if
you see I had only one server that I had
started which was my cop server and
automatically the other three instances
one is called noes. simply. in uh this
these two are the nodes and this is the
master node so these three got
automatically provision by the cops
command that I ran all right so this may
take a while for it to get validated a
good 5 to 10 minutes so what I'll do is
I'll pause the video now and I'll come
back once uh the server uh the cluster
is up and running it's been a good uh 8
to 9 Minutes uh since I started my
cluster so let me validate now okay
seems good so there's a master node uh
minimum One Max one some nodes which are
nothing but the slave noes or the worker
noes there are two of them T2 micro uh
subnet so my clusters seem to be up and
running and uh my cluster name is simply
learn. in so what I would want to do is
now let me just log into the master and
see if I can run some pods so let me get
back back to my inst installation steps
here the validation cluster is done so
let me log into my since my cluster name
is simply l.n this is the way to log
into my box so let me get into my box so
if you see here uh this is the host name
of the machine that I'm currently in if
you see this this is nothing but our
this cop server this is a server now
from here I'm trying to get into the
master box all right so if you see the
IP address has changed I was in a
different box I'm in a different box now
if I see host name you'll find a
different host name so this is 153 which
is nothing but the master node yep it's
153 this is the particular host so I'm
getting into this machine now so I
started the cluster from my cop server
here it ran and brought up three nodes
so I'm actually getting into my master
node and see if I can run some pots on
it all right so let me try Cub CTL uh
get cluster info try Cub CTL get nodes
all right so there are three nodes here
Master node and um one master node and
two worker notes so let me see if I have
some pods here ql get pods so there's no
pod as of now so what I'll try to do was
let me just pin up a very very simple
part just to check if my connections is
everything is correct or not correct I
have a simple um nodejs application that
I've built uh and I've got a container
for that this is already pushed to the
docker Hub register is called simply
learn Docker Hub and the image name that
I have here is called my node app and uh
I will use this image to power one of my
pods that I will run so this is the way
in which I'm going to launch my pod let
me show you these commands qctl run the
name for my deployment that I'm going to
run hyphen I image and this is the image
that is going to be powering my
container so this is simply learn doer
rub for/ myde app hyph replicas equal to
I want two replicas to be running and
the port that I want to expose this
particular pod is on 8080 so let me run
this as soon as this is run it creates
something called as a deployment all
right now let me just say um I'm not
really interested in the deployment I'm
interested in checking if at all the
parts are up and running so I will say
Cub get po all right so that was pretty
fast so I have two parts that are
running here these are two replicas
because I asked for two replicas these
parts are running so I can run Cube C
describe pod pickup all right I can pick
up any of the Pod name and see what is
the Pod what is the information does it
contain from what is the image that is
pulling what is the image image Name ID
this is actually running my pod which is
actually spinning up a container great
so far so good so in kubernetes the pods
can are ephemeral so they can be there
at any time cannot be at any time if I
need to expose my pod outside I will
have to create a service for my PO so
what I'll do is I'll create a very very
simple uh service by exposing this
particular uh deployment before that let
me check Cube serial get deployment so
there's a deployment that is created the
deployment name is simply an app app so
I will expose my deployment simply learn
app as um yeah I'll just expose this let
me see all right I'm not specifying what
type and all I don't want to get into
the complications of uh what are the
different types of exposing the service
and all that stuff so if I don't specify
anything uh it gives me something Clos a
cluster IP so this is where my pod is
actually exposed so let me just check if
at all this pod is up and running I'll
just try a simple curl command uh curl
HTTP colon this is my cluster IP and uh
the port is 88 if at all I hit this it's
actually hitting my application and
giving me uh whatever um I put a simple
uh sis. out kind of a thing where I'm
just printing um the container ID of
whatever pod is serving uh being served
out of so I'm actually hitting my
container and I'm getting this output
from the contain so everything looks
good my contain is up and running uh so
let me just go and clean it up I will
say Cub CTL uh Delete deployment simply
Lear app they should get rid of all the
parts that I created cubes TL getp all
right these parts are inter terminating
things let me just check cctl get
Services there's one service I don't
want this service let me delete that Cub
CTL delete service I want this all right
this looks good so let me come back to
my host my cop server from where I'm
running so I managed to successfully
verify this part see if everything is up
and running so what I'll do is I'll just
go ahead and complete this uh demo by
going and uh getting rid of my cluster
so cops delete cluster hyphen all right
so this will ensure that it will clean
up my complete uh cluster that I created
so I had three or four running instances
if you see them all the three are
shutting down because you know the cop
server which had cops installed on it uh
is now got a mandate to go ahead and
shut down and clean up the whole uh
instances and all those things that are
created as a part of my deployment thank
you for joining us on this insightful
journey through kubernetes on the simply
learn YouTube channel we hope this
tutorial has equipped you with a
comprehensive understanding of kuber
needs from the fundamentals to advanced
concepts if you found this video helpful
don't forget to like share and subscribe
for more enriching Tech content your
feedback matters so feel free to drop
your thoughts in the comment section
below stay tuned for more exciting
tutorials and until next time happy
learning and happy coding staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here